good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight so last thursday last
week on thursday talk show host stephen
colbert dispatched a group of seven of
his employees to washington dc their job
break into the u.s capitol complex and
harass lawmakers inside
so the group dutifully arrived in the
afternoon were met almost immediately by
uniformed capitol hill police officers
who threw them out
but apparently on orders from colbert
they returned at about 4 pm on thursday
the group re-entered the building
accounts vary as to what exactly
happened next but it seems clear that
colbert's employees were led inside by
an ally within the building that would
be a freshman member of congress from
massachusetts called jake auchenklaus
once on federal property colbert's
employees did what they came to do which
was disrupt the business of congress and
apparently they were not subtle about
doing it they pounded on doors and
yelled
whatever they did it got people's
attention it takes an awful lot for a
police force controlled by nancy pelosi
to arrest a group of left-wing
entertainment figures but that's exactly
what happened next capitol hill police
arrested seven colbert employees and
brought them to jail all seven of them
were charged with unlawful entry now
that's the identical charge that
hundreds of january 6 defendants have
been prosecuted for
but unlike january 6 defendants
colbert's employees were not sent to the
d.c jail for a year and a half in
solitary confinement no
they were released after only a night
behind bars and then they fled back to
new york
why is that what exactly is the
difference in the crime
as a legal question we still don't know
the answer for some reason capitol hill
police have not released the
surveillance tapes that would show
exactly what colbert's employees did
that so triggered the police force
controlled by nancy pelosi that they
were arrested
but whatever they did otherwise
sympathetic members of congress are
running away from it as quickly as they
can quote we do not condone any
inappropriate activity within the
capital jake auchenklaus's office told
us today though as a factual matter that
is not true
in fact jake ochencloth has a recent
history of condoning criminal behavior
in the capital
just this march surveillance cameras in
the complex caught jake auckland close's
chief of staff that would be a former
adam shift staffer called tim heisem
vandalizing the front door of
congresswoman marjorie taylor green's
personal office
heisem did this not once but several
times violently like a man obsessed
capitol police quickly filed an arrest
warrant against him because tim heissen
clearly posed a threat to a member of
congress
but jake hawking lost did not fire him
instead jake auchenklaus defended
heisem's vandalism as noble and
justified our office is not going to
apologize read a long and self-righteous
statement from jake auchenklaus in other
words we don't like marjorie taylor
green's politics therefore we can do
whatever we want to her and we will
for the most part the media ignored this
story so jake open close and adam schiff
felt emboldened to go further they
invited colbert's employees to the
capitol to harass marjorie taylor green
samore which is what they were trying to
do when they were arrested by capitol
hill police
now whatever you think of her politics
margaret taylor green is a sitting
member of congress preventing her or any
other member of congress from carrying
out official duties as a public
representative is by definition an
attack on democracy
so how is what stephen colbert did
different from what the protesters on
january 6 have been convicted of doing
that's a very good question and it's a
question that colbert himself spent the
weekend thinking about his conclusion
well
unlike trump voters stephen colbert is a
very good person therefore any
comparison to trump voters is not simply
ridiculous it is a moral crime watch
now it's predictable why these tv
talkers are talking like this on the tv
they want to talk about something other
than the january 6th hearings on the
actual seditionist insurrection that led
to the deaths of multiple people
and the injury of over 140 police
officers but drawing any equivalence
between rioters storming our capital to
prevent the counting of electoral
ballots and a cigar chomping toy dog is
a shameful and grotesque insult to the
memory of everyone who died and it
obscenely trivializes the service and
the courage the capitol police showed on
that terrible day
yeah
it was a toy dog it's shameful in other
words when you criticize me you're
really criticizing the brave capital
police officers who arrested the people
who worked for me the ones who committed
the crimes i asked them to commit and i
for one will not stand for that
that's what he just said
now what you have there is not so much
an explanation in fact it doesn't
explain anything instead it's a master's
class on whiny rich liberal
self-righteousness it's a distillation
of a worldview that is so concise and so
perfect it is certain to be studied by
cultural historians of the future
seeking to understand how our
civilization collapsed
not only am i not sorry you're the
criminal for bringing it up stop hitting
me he screams as he punches you in the
face
that is
passive aggression taken to the level of
art and anyway colbert says shut up i'm
his i'm a comedian with a toy dog you
can't criticize me
so the question really is is stephen
colbert a comedian
well if you're one of the relatively few
people still watching stephen colbert's
show on cbs you'll have to admit it is
hard to tell
most nights stephen colbert sounds like
the notably unfunny karine jean-pierre
he sounds like a biden flack delivering
whatever talking points the white house
tells him to repeat
and if you doubt that here's what it
looks like
ladies and gentlemen
joe biden did it
the biggest story continues to be the
one you were thinking about when you
weren't sleeping last night and it's the
one happening all over america the
protests in wake of the murder of george
floyd and please don't buy the false
narrative that these are lawless mobs
the vast majority of these protests have
been peaceful there's a simple if
extremely difficult solution reduce the
number of guns
we've done it before and it worked
russia's invasion of ukraine is a
humanitarian crisis but also it is a
triumph of humanity take that putin
okay so i might have the most privilege
of any white person you've ever met
how do i identify that in my own life
because i if i have white privilege i
want to be able to identify it give me
some hints as to my white privilege
[Music]
get the vacs peasants surrender your
guns support ukraine and remember it's
called kiev now
this isn't comedy it's a very sad
mid-life crisis but more than that it's
information war being waged against
television viewers on behalf of the
democratic party
at least when the white house press
secretary does it she admits what she's
doing colbert hides behind his former
job as a community it was all a joke
when people i don't like break into the
capital it's insurrection when we do it
it's sketch comedy
right it's getting harder to maintain
that lie and here's how you know
comedians have a sense of humor it is in
fact a job requirement but stephen
colbert does not stephen goldberg has
lost his sense of humor along with the
critical distance and perspective to
make humor possible
at this point he's just a partisan scold
and you know that for certain because
even as he watched the q and on shaman
parade around the capitol on january 6th
stephen colbert did not laugh now an
actual comedian whatever his politics
would have found that spectacle
hilarious because let's be honest it was
hey man
glad to see you guys you guys patriots
look at this guy he's got covered in
blood god bless you
yes sir
[Music]
[Music]
okay just want to let you guys know this
is like the sacred place
hey
this is the kind of bearskin in the
horned hat
that's not hilarious yes it is hilarious
no he's a
insurrectionist said colbert he needs to
go to jail he's a terrorist and when he
was sent to jail corbea applauded
now that's how maois cadres act that's
not how comedians act
so stephen colbert may be a late night
host still for some reason but he has
zero sense of humor
he ought to step aside and let some
young person
who still gets the joke to have the job
but he won't
he was colbert on november 6 2020. watch
and if you did not know that joe biden
was getting close
to 270 donald trump just provided all
the proof you will ever need
true story i'm wearing black tonight
because i was getting dressed this
afternoon
and i thought he might try some
shenanigans and it might be fitting to
tell jokes while wearing something
somber if he goes down that dark path so
we all knew he would do this
what i didn't know is that it would hurt
so much
those are real tears the only real thing
about that show we're not trying to
believe we're the point
but the guy's not a comedian you watch
the community you think that guy's
hilarious i'd love to meet him imagine
eating a meal with stephen colbert
chances are you somehow offend him over
the course of a typical dinner by saying
something he finds offensive or the
chance that 100
stephen colbert is a karen he's a
brittle middle-aged woman who's always
lecturing you about something in fact
he's elizabeth warren they even look
alike have you seen him in the same room
recently no
sad he was talented at one point so is
robert schmeigle that's one of the cold
bear employees who was also arrested
last week schmeichel's been doing his
dog puppet routine for 30 years that's
the one that colbert's know how do you
mind it was just a dog puppet
the dog papa was kind of funny during
the clinton administration is pure
hackery now
this michael keeps going because he's
got a political message for you i'm
going to beat you over there with my
political message
no one laughs at robert smeigle anymore
it's pathetic
who's funnier robert smeigle or the guy
who took pictures of himself at nancy
pelosi's desk on january 6th be honest
it's not even close the guy at pelosi's
desk is hilarious compared to the guy
with the talking dog and none of them is
half as funny again sorry it's true as
donald trump and how do you know that
show us the late night host who said
anything half as amusing as trump's taco
bowl tweet
ever any of them no never these people
are so afraid they're so terrified
holding on to their stupid jobs late
into middle age
then how do they respond to cinco de
mayo fawning over the indigenous cuisine
of the latinx community
nobody likes that
and that's why in the end stephen
colbert has not a single hispanic viewer
his audience is entirely self-hating
white liberals like him
so nobody watches anymore and that's
fine that's cbs's problem
but don't tell us you're a comedian and
therefore exempt from the normal rules
of behavior
and the normal federal laws about
trespassing
because you're not
you did what they did and you should be
punished in exactly the same way
subscribe to the fox news youtube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from tucker carlson
tonight